I tried to think of an opening joke for
this but it's really hard to make a
fourth-wall breaking joke when I'm
already talking to frankly at the camera
[Music]
Deadpool - new trailer which means yes
I'm putting up with more than one video
at a day somehow this became trailer
season maybe this happens every year
like with the Superbowl and then
immediately following I just forget but
yeah I'm flooded with stuff that I kind
of feel like I should talk about and
actually I want to talk about as well so
the new trailer for Deadpool is very
good and very enjoyable for a lot of
reasons and I will say this it's it's
made me and this isn't the first trailer
that I've thought this but it's probably
the first one I'm gonna vocalize it I
miss seeing trailers for the first time
in a theater and the trailer starts and
you don't know what it's for because how
straight face the thing starts right up
until the point that it freezes and
there's cables armed with the
green-screen sleeve and Deadpool starts
riffing on it it seems dead serious
right up to that point so you know it
will be very cool in a theater to have
it just stop dead like that when you
watch it online which is how most of us
see it when these trailers get released
you're clicking on a video link that
says Deadpool - trailer you know exactly
where it's going but that's a that's a
meta thing and the meta commentary seems
appropriate for a Deadpool trailer um
but in any case I'm actually quite
intrigued and impressed by Josh Brolin
is cable and I say surprisingly because
Josh Brolin is an actor who I've never
been particularly impressed by if he's
fine there's nothing wrong with him I've
never been in love with any of his work
and cable as a character that I kind of
actively disliked in my defense that's
based off what he was like in the 90s
maybe he got better after that I don't
know but he this is not a character I
enjoy at all but I like what I'm seeing
here I like how straightforward he is I
like how deadpan he is that is going to
play well off of Deadpool off of Ryan
Reynolds so that gives me a lot of hope
for that dynamic and how that's going to
play out the little snippets of action
that we get
we get a couple of it's it's cut
together there's a lot of cuts in it
which you usually get with the trailer
but we get enough long issue office that
I feel like I'm starting to get a feel
and a vibe for the action and how it's
gonna flow and how it's gonna look and
I'm liking everything that I'm seeing we
get a quick shot of Domino in action
which is nice we get a little bit of
that of that taxi driver again and I
kind of love the expression on his face
that like in this instant just says like
oh why don't I get myself into which is
nice that's a good vibe to get off him
especially because I was kind of
skeptical about bringing that character
back at all but you know you got that
and you've got TJ Miller look looking
like he's utterly failing at an action
scene you've got Deadpool's blind
roomate pointing a gun at not the person
who's actually there not where they are
and and and of course negasonic teenage
warhead so all this stuff just looks
really good
and that for me at this point is really
important because there was something
that I realized during sort of the
extended little divergence of Deadpool
playing with the action figures which is
funny and it's nice and it's fine but it
made me sort of realize something that I
think I kind of knew but hadn't really
fully formed the thought yet which was
that there is actually reason to be
nervous about a Deadpool 2 and that is
because Deadpool 1 you know was very
comedy heavy and that's not a bad thing
that worked for that film comedy sequels
are not known for being very good at all
like almost never and pretty much never
as good as the first time around because
comedy doesn't come any doesn't stand up
to repetition a lot and a lot of what
makes something you know that
gut-busting ly funny is the freshness
and the unexpectedness of it but you get
a second one even if the jokes are is
well delivered as they were the first
time they're not gonna play as well as
they did the first time they can't so
that makes me nervous when I stop and
think about that so
when I see these action beats and I'm
getting hints and I don't have a story
yet but I'm getting hints at that stuff
being really good and really solid that
gives me something that gives me some
assurance because the first Deadpool
while the action scenes were pretty good
the story was very profound Tori and was
really kind of only notable for being
told slightly out of sequence the way
that it was but really the story in the
origin and what was going on was not
particularly remarkable in that first
Deadpool movie what made that first epic
movie special was Deadpool himself and
the injection of his style of humor into
film but that's not gonna be new anymore
so going to the next one if they're
gonna retain that which they should it's
a big part of the character it's a big
part of this franchise system it's what
they it's what they're selling they need
to up the level of basically everything
else so so that his humor isn't having
to carry so much as it was the first
time around again not knocking the
action scenes or any of the rest of it
in the first movie but it was decent
if the humor hadn't been there in that
first movie it would not have been a
particularly remarkable movie so
everything that isn't the jokes needs to
up its game for this one and pretty much
all of what I'm seeing
feels like it's doing that the action
looks good it looks like they're
shooting it serious they're not shooting
it jokey which is good I think it would
have been an easy temptation to lean
harder into the jokes and the gags but
that's where it would all get stale so
this trailer honestly to me is just a
really big reassurance sort of even as
it reminds me boy the humor when you
keep kind of doing the same thing over
and over again that starts to lose its
weight but this trailer is showing me a
whole bunch of stuff that feels like
everything's up a notch and that's
exactly what I want exactly what I need
from this film so I think that's about
it it was a good trailer I liked it and
just sort of got me thinking about the
sequel in general sort of the hurdle
that it has to overcome being at least
in part a comedy sequel like I said kind
of a kiss of death historically speaking
but in any case
Deadpool - did you see this trailer oh
so whatever your thoughts are drop
something
the comments let's talk about it there's
all that stuff you can do you can
support me on patreon I got swag you can
get by doing so I'm also on Twitter and
I got a podcast and I got links for all
that stuff in the description so until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]